the game spot news of the day is a
double dose of mjolnir might plus an
upcoming test flight in halo infinite
will allow players to taste campaign
co-op details of god of war ragnarok's
collector's editions have reportedly
leaked amid a whirlwind of rumors around
an upcoming announcement for the game's
release date are details of what fans
could expect the more pricey versions of
it to include according to the leaks the
tier above the standard release will be
known as the yotner edition referencing
the giants of jotenheim this edition
will include a one-to-one replica of the
game's version of mjolnir which was
briefly teased at the very end of god of
war 2018. considering thor will be a
major character in the upcoming sequel
the mighty weapon is likely to be
prominently featured in the title there
will also reportedly be an even pricier
collector's addition beyond that
including a map of the game world badges
and potentially additional items of
course the biggest question on
everyone's mind is when can we get our
hands on the game and fair anyone
wondering the answer to that just
remember that god of war 2018's release
date announcement happened three months
before that game came out so even if god
of war ragnarok is still slated for
holiday 2022 there's plenty of time for
the team at sony santa monica to give us
that information from one mjolnir to
another xbox is giving away another
limited edition series x this time in
celebration of the release of the
upcoming marvel film for love and
thunder the design is a match made in
asgard for the boxy console which is
wrapped in a skin to replicate the god
of thunder's trusty hammer mjolnir
featuring cracks along its faces to
resemble its reforging after its
destruction at the hands of heller in
for ragnarok the promotional image of
the xbox also features the weapon's
handle sticking out from the back side
if the handle is indeed a part of the
final product hopefully the winner is
worthy of this godly gift so they can
actually pick it up and put it on their
tv stand the giveaway also features a
custom xbox mjolnir controller but there
are no images of that at this time for
anyone that wants to enter the giveaway
head over to xbox's twitter and retweet
that post about it with the hashtag thor
love and thunder xbox sweepstakes strap
into that mjolnir armor spartan because
it's time to test halo infinite's online
campaign co-op along with mission
replayability something that was also
missing with the game's launch sorry no
local cooperative at this moment still
players will need to sign up for the
test flight which will occur in a
separate instance of the game from any
progress you've made thus far in the
campaign and any progress you make in
the test flight cannot be brought over
one of the main points according to the
team on getting online campaign co-op up
and running was the game becoming
unstable when players strayed too far
away from one another in the test flight
teammates will only be able to stray 800
feet away from anyone else in the group
before getting a warning to return at 1
000 feet that play has respawned
immediately back with their team 343
industries primary software engineer
lead isaac bender assures players that
that distance is enough for teams to
attack the campaign's biggest covenant
bases from opposite sides with room to
spare that's it for today's gamespot
news thank you so much to everyone that
has joined me for my first week of
videos devonte will be your host next
week enjoy your long weekend and he will
see you on tuesday right here at
gamespot